[Music]
it's been a long eight years but we're
finally returning to the old West in Red
Dead Redemption too sure it may have a
two in the title but the game actually
serves as both the prequel and companion
piece to the original so what better
time to revisit the plot of 2010's
excellent Red Dead Redemption after all
we know for sure that we're gonna be
seeing a lot of familiar faces in Red
Dead 2 before we get into the recap if
you're itching for more gun slinging
action make sure to check back every
Friday here on GameSpot for our new show
quick-draw where we'll be riding out to
explore the vast world of Red Dead
Redemption to 1911 and America is
undergoing huge changes the wild
frontiers are being tamed by new
technologies and the burgeoning ideals
of civilization while the outlaws that
once roamed free are slowly being
snuffed out one by one and in Red Dead
Redemption we played as a character
whose story truly embodied those
changing times
[Music]
hello friend after his parents died john
marston grew up under the care of dutch
vanderlin a gang leader who reveled in
the cruelty and brutality of the Old
West
Marsden rode alongside Dutch for years
but he was gravely wounded during a
botched robbery and the gang who he
called family left him behind to die
this acted as a wake-up call for John so
he took his wife Abigail the young son
Jack and fellow gang member uncle no
relation to set up a ranch where they
lived a quiet honest life for five years
that is until the Bureau of
Investigation
under orders of the government came
knocking ordered to clear out the
remaining gangs and bring order to the
land using any means necessary their
lead agent edgar ross decides to use
john to find the people he needs
Ross has Abigail and Jack kidnapped and
held to ransom they'll only be released
if John assists the bureau in tracking
down former members of his old gang
starting with Bill Williamson
John and Bill frequently butted heads
while riding together in Duchess gang so
it doesn't take long for their reunion
at Fort Mercer to go sour
despite John pleading with Bill to
surrender bill has one of his men shoots
John instead before he can bleed out
John is found by a local rancher Bonnie
McFarlane well you're alive
so it would seem Bonnie pays for a
doctor to treat Marsten's wounds and he
does odd jobs around the ranch to repay
the debt but Bill Williamson hearing
that John survived his gunshot wound
send some men to the McFarland ranch to
flush him out John saves the ranch
workers but realizes that he's going to
need some assistance in taking on bill
at the heavily fortified four Mercer
so John gets involved with some of new
Austin's more colorful characters
including literal snake oil salesman
nigel west dickens who points him
towards irish a drunkard with a hook up
to get john access to a Gatling gun and
seth a grave robber slash treasure
hunter who has methods to sneak into
Fort Mercer John also assists the local
u.s. marshal lead Johnson and his
dim-witted deputies and in doing so
captures one of Williamson's men hog
time let's get him to jail Williamson in
return kidnaps Bonnie McFarlane after
rescuing her the time finally comes to
take the fight to bill using west
dickens armored stagecoach Irish's
Gatling gun the marshals men and sets
distractions the ragtag gang stormed the
fort
[Applause]
only to find that Williamson isn't there
and his fled to Mexico to seek aid from
another ex gang member
Javier he's gone to see Javier escuela
[Music]
[ __ ] all shouting it jump on Shawn
beginning with one of the most iconic
moments in modern gaming the second act
of Red Dead Redemption takes us south of
the border into Mexico
[Music]
in order to gain information on
Williamson and escuelas whereabouts
Marston must help Colonel a yen day and
captain de santé of the Mexican army as
they struggle to quash a rebellion led
by the charismatic and amorous man of
the people
Abraham Reyes My dear boy don't be a sir
I'm going to be the next president of
America but Marston isn't exactly loyal
to the Mexican army he's there for one
reason and one reason only to find bill
and Xavier so he ends up playing both
sides
teaming up with not only Reyes and his
paramour Luisa but also legendary
gunslinger Landon Ricketts who
incidentally would be a perfect
character to explore more in Red Dead
Redemption too especially as he was the
lone survivor of a massacre in
Blackwater in 1899 you know the same
year as Red Dead Redemption to set the
game that starts with a huge incident in
Blackwater anyway a nd Cotton's on that
John isn't necessarily in his corner and
orders his execution the rebels arrived
in the nick of time to save John and
together they kill captain to Santa they
storm the army stronghold of El Presidio
and capture escuela before killing both
a na and John's mark Bill Williamson
sadly Louisa dies during the attack not
that Ray is noticed with John's business
in Mexico finally over he heads back to
America to meet with Edgar Ross and get
his family back
[Music]
well it was never going to be that easy
was it
Ross refuses to release John's family
until he tracks down and kills Dutch
who's making trouble after forming a new
gang it's nice to see you John hello
Dutch Abigail well I hope ain't seen her
for a while this new gang is made up of
young Native Americans who were angry at
the US government for taking their land
and by extension their livelihoods John
works with Yale professor and cocaine
enthusiast Harold mcdougal who is on
sabbatical after some kind of
cocaine-related meltdown where he
attacked a man what civilization is all
about they're all red skins and the nubs
at Yale
I have always both desires he's studying
the Native Americans and the bureau
enlisted his help in tracking down
Dutchess new gang but there's a better
more reliable lead in the form of nastas
a member of Dutchess gang who's also
working as an informant for Ross and the
bureau after a cat and mouse game with
Dutch eventually they track him down to
his hideout and storm the place with the
US Army John confronts Dutch who
realizes the world is changing and that
he can't keep fighting it so chooses to
kill himself rather than be captured or
killed by John
our time is past
believing that his journey is finally
over John eventually gets to go home and
is reunited with his family
however Ross doesn't keep his end of the
promise he brings members of the bureau
and the US Army to attack the Marston
ranch uncle is shot and killed John
makes sure that Abigail and Jack escape
by horseback before sacrificing himself
[Music]
[Music]
the game's epilogue takes place three
years after John's last stand Abigail
has also died and Jack now on his own
decides to exact his revenge on Ross he
tracks down the now-retired agent who's
living in a cabin near a lake with his
wife
Jack confronts Ross and challenges him
to a duel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in Red Dead Redemption - we'll be
getting a closer look at the early years
of the Marston family as they rode with
Dutchess gang but will there be other
familiar faces we should be looking out
for well we don't have long to wait the
game finally launches on October 26th
make sure to tune in to GameSpot every
Friday for more features about Red Dead
Redemption - last week on quick draw we
took a look at all of the previous
rockstar games that have inspired Red
Dead in one way or another and for more
features about the game make sure to
check back here every Friday and we'll
see you next time
[Music]